[Musique]
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
le et
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
oh
pour
alors voilà c'est prêt meyer dix ans ici
ça c'est une bonne idée m'a chanté ça se
voit là voilà c'est une troisième place
était parfait
frédéric mitterrand mais je vais
demander qu'il soit là berléand puis
mitterrand d'un côté bernard note anne
aymone voilà non car 0 ou le lol alors
juliette alors que les grandes gueules
c'est thomas un peu plus discret que les
autres karine ambrosio et aulas on n'a
pas fini la situation et décibels
le ps c'est bien ça non bravo mon image
on voit la moelle à
tallinn vallée bougies on attend un peu
non ouais j'espère que le chandelier
europe en dessous huawei c'était beau
marque continue de glisser entre vous
[Musique]
bon alors qu'un très élevé le moins bien
avocate rien c'est pas moi c'est
fabuleux bien j la barque et le rôle ok
oui allô oui c'est frédéric mitterrand
quatrième à bien
oui
[Musique]
christophe tu veux pas présenter ton ami
il va se présenter tous almasy je
m'appelle anthony très bien anthony les
millions de tonnes mt de quelle origine
anthony la guadeloupe vous engagez des
antillais
[Musique]
pour t'expliquer le chrome esquissé un
accra fois drame
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur vous fera plaisir tiens
vraiment plaisir de voir ça va très très
bien
tout va bien à la cuisine on va manger
les chromes explique comment expliquer
ce que c'est à est-ce que les crocs mais
ce qu'ils sont prêts pour monsieur
whisky chrome skis je vais là voilà ça
c'est des croix attention alors frédéric
tu mettais comme toi de me voir souvent
très content vraiment tu le sais en plus
tu mets tout dans ta bouche était dans
la boue c'est et surtout tu ne croque
pas non mais il craque jamais parce que
gagner à croquer oui il a été recouvert
entièrement par le contenu de ces
lettres contenu d'accord voilà les
chrétiens papa de chez moi mon attention
1 2 3
à fondre bon pourquoi son
nom bon
comme le programme comme le brozec
dis moi tu penses que tu passes ta vie à
faire des trucs intéressants toi au
moins je travaille beaucoup on ne
s'assoit pas beaucoup prendre un chemin
rebelles et photonique c'est bien
l'ancien ballon j'ai fait ça avec un
garçon qui est très gentil je crois
qu'il a invité tout à
fait d'autres choses
je prépare là une grande exposition sur
grace kelly ah ouais
4500 m² à
monter car ça va être très beau avec
toutes les robes toutes les led edge
coque mais la ville et de la gare de
vannes
alors donc là aussi
j'ai un livre auquel je tiens beaucoup
qui sortira pour le festival de cannes
il s'appelle le festival de cannes ah
oui mais qui racontent le festival de
cannes à ma manière à dire comme je les
ai vécues depuis que c'est l'occasion de
le suivre c'est à dire il ya longtemps
déjà avec des tas petite histoire
personnelle qui se mêle à la l'histoire
fait commune tant qu'on s'est pas vu ça
fait une paye donc se doit montrer d'une
année un bonne année que juste à ma
gauche juste à côté de moi c'est bien
moi la garde et on se connaît dans le
regard des gens est formidable je n'ai
malheureusement pas lui l'homme
invisible aurait peut être répondre à
galérer faire un livre s'appelle l'homme
invisible à la télé tous les jours mais
il est très très formidable et très
médiatique oui et alors ça a été assez
long pour lui au début je pense que là
il prend une revanche il fait toutes les
apparitions télé qui l'a pas fait
pendant toute sa carrière parce qu'en
fait il a mis des années avant d'y
arriver un peu dans mardi tia a peinte
en invités avaient militants jusqu'à ce
qu'il devienne une star que maintenant
ce web
fortin
[Musique]
beaucoup
oui allô c'est karl et françois 8 au
quatrième merci
ségolène c'est qu'elle a du charme ses
volets
non mais dans la vie
alan jara d'abord on a vraiment du
charme
comme un jeu quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est
attend même
sort
bonsoir monsieur mais bon on peut c'est
normalement il y avait un vieux voilà ça
t gil et maintenant c'est françois à
françois barat comme tu as en toi cgc
n'a fait dégueulasse de charsadda c'est
pourquoi bon ok d'accord d'arrêter
ou est ce qu on se déshabille je prends
votre manteau vous allez passer en
cuisine tout à fait d'accord avec
plaisir
que ça mais voilà mais voilà mais voilà
qu'est ce qui passait sur internet tu
seras une star enfin eric la vie
du quartier
ça lui est arrivé à ces campagnes en
france depuis qu'il a lu son cancer
du sein cancer mais les bains à la
tienne carlito santé dégradé subi sa 6e
à ce que tu fais tiens tu fais tu fais
un journal fait un journal quotidien sur
la net oui non mais ce qui est génial
c'est de raconter telle idée est-ce que
tu m'épates angie tu veux qu'on
travaille dans la rue non bien sûr je
fais ça tous les jours que dieu fait et
alors bah j'ai commencé il ya très peu
de temps il ya à peine une semaine mais
ça marche très très bien il a vu
l'appareil qu'il a c'est un téléphone un
téléphone portable tu vois non si
j'étais ici et moi je sais comment toi
tu es superbe tu peux on peut pas te
filmer
11-3 mais il ya une dizaine d'années
c'est à dire c'est que rien pendant
combien de temps tu vas nous faire sur
l'autonomie je veux dire l'autonomie
16h16
qui sort et sarko ségo et sarko seront
un nato alors là il est sortie en vod il
est sorti en dvd il va sortir en salles
le 4 avril a montré un extrait le tube
je mens de salut les terriens à
l'endroit où les monter ce film est au c
c'est le boulevard exelmans aux
angoisses et nos verts et du monteur
l'alimentaire saf et rick des escort boy
mais aussi tu veux tout animal est un
moteur c'est frédéric oui je sais je
rappelle il a une scène où ils ont fait
une caméra cachée ségolène royal est
donc est en train de dans un car ou
auchan dans un garage dans un garage et
les mecs commence à dont csd ça fait
chic aux genres discothèque il ya
ségolène royal qui regarde ça c'est
extraordinaire ça ce qu'attendait
surprise surprise le très beau mec qui
viennent de chez plat ni menteur
alimentaire mais ça devrait faire
connaître auprès du moteur je voudrais
wilfried et karim de la dernière fois
ils sont toujours disponibles mais avec
internet c'est fini c'est à madame
claude tout ça c'était le bon temps
maintenant les maquis bonbons acidulés
dans la dernière passe est très très
dangereux ouais parce que y'a pas les
photos il ya deux leviers des ris
pas tu draine beaucoup plus longtemps
moi j'ai pas l'ordinateur son mari suis
totalement végétarien on a toujours le
droit de fumer chez toi tu peux faire
tout ce qu ici on n'est pas la télé
c'est pas un bureau si tu aime l'odeur
du tabac et j'aime tout valoriser le
cigare quand je dresse qu'il soit à pau
est-ce qu'on va parler politique ce soir
bien sûr françois berléand vous avez
déclaré nous avait du vent je veux bien
que le charisme de nous il pas dit ça
non ils adorent bayrou je vais déclarer
qu'il adore oui malheureusement j'avais
déclaré comme qu'elle compte dans une
mais autrefois non je dise il ya eu le
cas d'une ouïe mais je vais voter pour
lui c'était pas méchant c'est que tu as
raison mais le charisme d'une ouïe mais
j'espère bien qu'il sera élu la pièce de
théâtre écoute ça marche je n'en reviens
pas on a une vraiment raté la mecque
faut le faire il faut une pièce sur le
cancer les gens vont le voir vous ne
savez pas que la pièce avait des vertus
comique donc
on a répété bon c'était une femme qui un
cancer que quand dsk
tri de 50 missions les dix déclarent
pour la sixième fois
jusqu'à détenir elle est vraiment et
bouleversant siens et il se trouve que
l'avant qu'elle n'arrive ya
un quart d'heure vingt minutes où les
gens se marrent mais du début jusqu'à la
fin parce que bon il trouve ma joue un
personnage un petit peu cynique afin
professeur de médecine un petit peu
cynique un peu son assistance et de
l'aisance et sert de maison c'est drôle
j'aime cette idée de parler du concert
d'en rire de moi tu fais des check-up
tous les ans je sais que moi j'ai décidé
au congrès at war tulipes au congrès
avec celle mais qui ne fait pas de
chacun et qui pense toute la journée
qu'il est mal à moi je suis le mec qui
est la maladie qui le reste du temps son
band est situé cette idée d'assister à
ta décrépitude en direct tu vois se dire
que chaque année on dit ça mais moi j'ai
dit c'est les mêmes ordinateurs et les
mêmes chiffres donc le mec te dis là
vous avez pris un l'avouer perdu ça tu
vois tu vois arriver la mort on dirait
tu fais quoi tu fais de scanner ils me
font tout tout tout lécher les doigts
dans le fait aussi pour le procès c'est
ce qu'écrit chaque instant la prochaine
échéance le fait toutes les semaines
et ça m'a dit que le spi s'amender mais
ça c'est le sera
l'opérateur
free l'écart et kirsten prout en général
non moi ils m'ont rendu un très mauvais
service parce qu'ils m'ont mis des
fellahs total ils ont mis des caméras
dans les poumons tu vois dans les
bronzes les bronchioles et les mecs me
dit une fois qu'ils m'avaient évidemment
il dit c'est quand même marrant en fumée
depuis calage dix films depuis l'âge de
17 ans et 10 mois on savait les poumons
bébé alors tu as quand on me dit ça
shake m'avait dit tu crois qu'ils
voudront par poumon tu me salis il faut
que j'arrête mais là c'est vrai parce
qu'en même temps voilà ça peut aussi ne
peux pas t'aider tu vois je suis seul
hôpital américain parce qu'en fait ça
quand j'étais petit et que je disais
paris match qui a été ma culture avec
europe 1 mais toutes les stars allaient
mourir à l'hôpital américain il ya des
gens des photos volées
carrière voit le poker hier un devenir
une star 2 allée à l'hôpital américain
voilà quelle mourir à l'hôpital
américain avec les paparazzi que
l'effroi du m'ouvre à l'hôpital amérique
j'espère moi je vais contre l'hôpital
américain je suis pour le service public
et moi je vais l'hôpital mais en effet
pour ton truc la ddc qu'il a été malade
c'est pas non mais je vois un truc un
truc il peut pas se dire parce que c'est
maxine c'est pas qu'il ait avouables
c'est qu'il vient pas vinci vient pas du
monde s'appelle ainsi la fumée trop de
gandja la non j'ai fait une double
perforation bouchée des intestins
puisque c'est que sétif et françois ou
où seront maintenant tu me déçoit
énormément et
j'ai fait une connerie et
s'est allongé les punaises n'ont pas du
tout j'avais des
comme si le mot n'est dit diverticules
pour lui l'état est alors quand on en
reste quand on en fait de suite on doit
se faire opérer hélas masser par
coelioscopie c'est le nombre il exige en
effet cinq de suite su que j'ai une
théorie françois si j'étais président de
la république d'accor asie mon ministre
de la santé avec un
président ambitieux parce que je dirais
tous les français ont droit chaque année
à un check up gratuit et obligatoire
ceux qui font le check up sont
remboursés par la sécu ceux qui ne font
pas de checa ne sont pas remboursés par
la sécu et oui mais je peux te dire que
tous et on les dépisteurs elle est
malade on les soigne les avants qui
coûtent une fortune à la collectivité
voilà voilà une mesure à la fois pop il
y
un praticable
leurs bouteilles à 64 millions de gens
qui vient de faire le check up et à ses
statuts tan mal à toi non mais nantes
reçoit troyes avec ton petit mot est
peut-être non c'est fini je n'ai plus de
problème de pénis a duré combien de
temps le stick bride 6 in win 6 il bride
non non le sig wypall si si
tu sais quoi parlait de maladie j'ai
découvert ça ça j'adore bientôt parano
lifting c'est le tien est très réussie
frieden et 9 encore là ça il faut me
griller de là il ne fait pas de détails
mais je t'en supplie jeu très bien ce
sera les yeux simplement je serai pas de
toi suppose ressemblera pleinement
[Musique]
mais très attention mais l'eau oui
bonsoir anne aymone julie qui a mal aux
pieds y est les thomas juliette logique
à ses yeux ça commence bien
[Musique]
et je lui dis mais faut que je fasse le
lifting et ou le blanchiment des dents
est une lutte à kiev et à la palette
graphique
j'ai dit même quand ça bouge aussi
la palette graphique altorf est tout
neuf photoshop quand ça bouge c'est la
pagaille j'ai enfin donc gérard le
lifting numérique bonheur très bien
j'ai bien aimé êtes vous avez raison
je veux prendre bêtement s'il vous plaît
titularisation ce
même métier qu'on avait mal aux pieds
quand j'ai froid aux pieds what the moon
is dieu
leur inscription
honnêtement le vieillissement n'est pas
le cas l'an prochain non parce qu'on se
rend pas compte d'abord le but en plus
un ping est un ver dans ce sens qu'ils
ont c'est est ce qu'on a peur de mourir
catholique normalement il paraît qu'on
doit pas avoir peur moi j'ai pas peur
que je t'ai pas vu
les transferts aux fastes gauche
bonjour venait bien de
tons chair et les os il commence par
nous péter bale a
dynamisé qua non voilà j'en ai deux mois
j'ai toujours eu des chats et puis quand
tu voyages comme ça tu peux pas avoir
des chats donc j'avais plus d'animal et
c'est celui christine bravo qui m'a
sauté sur les genoux coudes je
suis tombée enceinte et agathe ce chien
près de chez huawei c'est ça ah bon il
est mignon que j'en ai un comme ça un
des deux comme ça et après ça c'est pas
de nom j'ai appelé mp3 comment tu là
on a trouvé des tombes
où il ya des chinois la drogue est
terrible il faut arrêter de
cannabis avec un effet sur les gens en
fait c'est même pas la peine et on le
sait on sur le voile a aidé on l'a
trouvé des tombes et oui voilà
au mexique on a trouvé les mêmes général
reims est le riche monsieur la garçon
voilà je vais vous expliquer parce que
ces chiens là on les retrouve aussi sur
des peintures de médiévales européennes
donc on suppose qu'ils ont qui sont
d'origine asiatique puisque l'accueil en
l'air ces chiens asiatiques qui ont été
manifestées le plus vieux bonsaï du
monde - s'est magnifié par les
asiatiques au paléolithique à l'époque
où ils ont passé ils sont allés peu plus
l'amérique en passant le détroit de
béring j'étais pas mal alors en glace
rendu coûterait
désordre royaux des beaux voiture luc
bat parce que je trouvais été l'année
d'été mais encore
une question est-ce qu'ils puissent
partout le tir mais non à ben alors
encore simplement cottier a mené
quotidien il faut absolument marquer le
territoire parce qu'un rival qu'elle
alors là oui la séquence qui peut
considérer françois gagnon comme ils
n'ont
donc pas remplacer les mecs par le chien
c'est à dire oui mais là faut rentrer la
bête entière donc
alors qu'est ce tu fais tu vas un film
je sors
tu vas sortir en même temps sur les
écrans et mai en dvd c'est quoi ça
s'appelle c'est pas moi ouais écoute
c'est une comédie dont je suis fort
satisfaite parce que d'abord lé mot va
ch mans enlevé rigolote comédie
policière
mais tu vois que franco québécoise et le
truc original là dedans c'est que tout
le monde parle français ouais mais comme
évidemment entre le québécois de
montréal elle joue elle du
lac-saint-jean le voir chercher à
comprendre
parigot muller essaye de nous faire le
marseillais en fait venue du muller ont
puis je sais pas quoi est à le belge
tableaux etc et donc perdre ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire qu'est ce qu'il
dit lui puisqu'il a dit j'avais compris
donc de filmer sous titres et
[Applaudissements]
non dans la face à toulouse a fait un
bond alors comment ça va la toise les
sur i télé lui à lui il a quitté tf1 m6
partition très bien ici moi je regarde
la télé toute la journée ça social que
je regarde chaque du tofu et sur la tnt
le sien défaveur le gros machin sur le
toit l'internaute et
la tnt ta vieille antenne tu mets un
adaptateur et tu à la télé tu as tord le
cou les jours 18h10 je veux qu'on s'est
quand même ken et barbie
tu peux me l'as tu peux avoir
c'est vrai que itélé c'est vachement
bien oui et puis moi j'ai l'impression
d'avoir ouvert les fenêtres
car il relève par mois donc oui d'après
risques fous je suis parti un peu fâché
et j'ai été accueilli sur une chaîne ou
jeu mais c'est juste que je veux je fais
ce que j'ai une heure et demie tous les
jours pour faire mon métier
là tu es un ami
tu prends la tnt c'est quand tu
l'apprends battu à plat revendeurs
magasin tu achètes un adaptateur pour à
80 euros est
désormais tu reviendras notre jeune ami
[Musique]
oui bon sur un carillon broccio
et sur l'étang de berre
[Musique]
c'est pas là
je le garde
ouais
bonsoir
papa
quant aux vêtements
[Musique]
m
on y va alors dans made in erba dit et
je crois bien
c'est sur le tube joe lutte elle appelle
elle l'appelle cacahuètes non mais c'est
ma cacahuètes c'est sur le
séjour et bien en toi non remplies par
ce soir
les noms y aller voir s est fait on ne
sait pas voilà
françois via mon petit françois
k
o
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
alors très bon tu vas voir john paul et
jérôme scache foie gras totana pas lui
voilà c'est très bien je me suis pris 2
et truchement casse croûte de homard
samedi sont minces père jean maury les
vacherins contemporain s'est
félicité thierry alors je le dis c'est
nous seigneur bénisse et se repassent
qu'ils ont préparé et procurer du pain à
ceux qui n'en ont pas a dit souhaiter
c'était au début de l'année 2006
bernadette chirac pour la première fois
à l'elysée dont captait pas très loin
d'ici elle avait fait il y avait dix
falcou qui était là il y avait une
légion d'honneur je sais pas pour un
homme d'affaires oracle open chirac et
bernadette chirac c'était arrangé avec
di falco pour faire une prière au début
ou à la fin du repas et il y avait quoi
10 12 personnes invitées donc petit rac
et jacques chirac ont pas fait la prière
et par et ils se sont éclos t-rex temps
pressé d'aller quand les invités sont
parties d'aller leur dire surtout ne
racontez pas cette histoire parce qu'ils
allaient honte mais c'est pour montrer
son pouvoir de plus en plus elle
installe restait la royauté enfin
jusqu'à la fin de mois à l'elysée toufik
n'a jamais été vu main sur bernadette
chirac la survenue de madame
chapeau avec 100 circonflexe
on a essayé de faire un film sur l on
avait rapporté auparavant lui a demandé
d'autorisation il faut de la rencontre
et une fois qu'on a commencé le film
mais on va pas commencer un un film sur
une femme politique c'est une femme
politique elle et lui depuis 30 ans
encore est donc c'était ça qui nous
intéresse est sans faille à tous et donc
il ya trente mille conseillers fiscaux
non en france elle prend trois heures à
la télé quand il veut elle prend france
3 3 heures quand elle veut pour aucun
trucage
les
chaînes publiques et gêne privés doivent
payer pour ça et personne n'ose poser
une question à madame chirac jamais
personne n'avait vu un film science sur
elle cette critique équilibré mais
critique un peu emmerdeur et donc c'est
vrai que toi tu décides de faire un film
sur elle et alors voilà à tailler une
séquence génial c'est que tu lui
demandes il est sympa et le fait passer
pour un journaliste belge et lui n'ont
cessé marchant dans la rue comme ça ils
arpentent dans la rue et demande s'il
peut poser une question elle lui répond
mais enfin écoutez vous voyez mes mais
non mon secrétariat il dit oui mais
enfin bon jour juste une question là
maintenant enfin puisque vous êtes belge
la reine machin et la princesse mathilde
vous les interrogez riez pas dans la rue
ainsi croire on sait qu'elle se prend
pour la reine de la république ouais et
donc pour moi journaliste je trouvais ça
bien d'essayer de montrer pas la face
sombre parce que c'est pas ça s'est
passé par un pamphlet smig de crack non
plus bernaquez non non il ya eu des
histoires un peu des frais de bouche
c'est prescrit euralair mais l'inscrit
place l'instruction n'était pas ouverte
mais c'était pas ça le problème c'était
ce qu'on peut voir comment elle agit
pour distiller de la liberté du citoyen
voilà exactement c'est ça tester
résidents et les gens n'avaient rien
ordinaire
met d'accord mais et non effectivement
un moment donné elle n'est pas contente
mais on la suit elle veut pas nous vous
répondrons nous on a choisi loin fait ça
avec génial je reste loin d'elle
aux autres journalistes et là cela
m'énerve et donc si de me coller à elle
est là elle saute au bout d'un moment
elles sautent sur la perche et elle va
pousser le preneur de son qui sait pas
ce qui lui arrive et laurie deux essais
cgt lui prend sa chance c'est normal
qu'on ait droit de l'interroger mais
j'ai vu un peu de l'intérieur comment ça
et ces gens là sont aussi des gens
beaucoup plus fragile que vous ne pensez
et donc
moi je sais j'aime pas je n'aime pas
aller les emmerder voilà ces moments où
je
fais pas le malin toi tu défends le
système au fait non je défends pas
qu'est-ce que tu défends frédéric jeux
des films et cdg défend les gens qui
gèrent une prière mais non mais très
bien défendre les gens que j'aime donc
j'ai bonne mémoire en tant que personne
quand on est en train de parler de ça
dans un dîner sympathique et au fond ian
paice de consensus qui consiste à dire
que ce que fait jean paul john paul
lepers et c'est normal c'est bien eric
rail à un consensus bon eh bien moi même
si je suis le seul à partager ce
consensus je dirais que malgré tout je
n'aime pas qu'on attaque quelqu'un que
j'aime bien l'histoire comme madame
chirac
tu vas vraiment soutenir josé bové et je
soutiens à bloc
voilà toujours fait disons que je
souffle donné l'idée de tenir ses
concerts
mais comment faut changer le système
faut commencer à penser l'économie est
remonté on s'est connu à porto allègre
oui on s'est vus motion trois fonds
social mondial mais c'est vrai que là
bas
j'ai eu et on a eu en fait on se
soutient c'est le slogan pardon vous
deux on se voit on se connaît pas le nom
de mont dol est possible et un autre
monde est possible
il ya eu un bon tir et c'est ce que j'ai
dit j'ai j'ai cette sensation
là bas j'ai eu la sensation que c'était
frais c'est à dire qu'il y avait
suffisamment d'énergie avec mais le club
méditerranée des bobos portola et
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
des morts
là ils sont bien d'entrée
quelques
dîners avec ligne assurera monnaies avec
danielle mitterrand simplement
le mot sympa ta belletante
qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas beaucoup avec
elle que ça va peut-être si non je
n'aime pas mais qui
n'est pas critique mais totalement si
simple que ça mais elle est totale avec
toutes avec nous enfin le temps de
partir tu vois que tu étais pas je suis
pas d'accord avec elle du tout jeune et
j'ai une certaine affection pour elle
parce que ça tient qui en a bavé dans la
vie mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
allant du tout aujourd'hui mois julia tu
es devenu milliardaire ah ouais ça y est
avec les droits d'auteur ouais c'est ça
dont il
est l'auteur de quoi avec ça une pièce
que tu es le gros succès de l'année
dernière elle fait une verrue c'est le
plus gros succès c'était mais tu passes
à laquelle s'est renseigné reconnaît que
personne ne nous donnait gagnante parce
que la hauteur
du banc du blé ah ben oui tout et trois
en tant qu'auteurs on est à 33 chacune
oui forcément ça nous fait super bien
vivre à jamais ou c'est bien vécue même
à la télé je gagne moins 5 heures et
offrir un animateur de taizé sur le
retour
tu n'es pas un homme marié catholique et
royal non moi j'ai arrêté les hommes
mariés en 82 ouais j'ai beaucoup fait et
j'ai arrêté beaucoup d'animations ces
deux ans pour partir les deux ans que ça
fait lamentable 92 la rigueur qui
arrivait c'est ça non c'est la fin d'un
ba s'était arrêté tout à la fin
mais
simone
et toi que tu fais karine silla one
woman show - le deuxième je m'amuse mois
d
des clichés qu'on a aussi bien sûr les
filles que sur les mecs moi je trouve
que c'est bien de parler déjà de dire la
vie de couple ça se passe comme ça c'est
un vivier énorme de situations comiques
de la ville qu'on cherche au sun ouais
leur écart un fonds américain voilà fond
la caisse c'est dans quel théâtre au
trévise et ça s'appelle dressing room
est un
et c'est top c'est un bonheur pseudo
marche ah ouais tu prend de l'argent au
dessus ça va commencer modesto joe louis
basse elle commence donc ça moi
j'aimerais m'entretenir maintenant tu
voyages que j'ai pu mais en même temps
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens j'étais
peut-être le temps passe moi j'ai des
chances d'y arriver est ce que vous
savez que berné on paye les sf depuis
cette année
j'ai payé à 58 après ouais l'asarcm
à figures toi un appartement de famille
et tout à coup j'ai un coup de fil de ma
soeur qui le dit mais dis donc tu veux
mais tu sais qu'on est soumis à l isf
chez vous
vous avez toute la maison c'est normal
machin tout que j'écris une jolie elle
est gentille au fisc en disant qu'à
écouter s'cusez moi où
j'avais un peu zappé dsf voilà
ils sont beaux les révolutionnaires des
choses et
moi on est riche on sortait pas
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de supporteurs
de josé bové qui sont soumis à l isf
louis chanseau quasiment tous mais
josé devrait supprimer les sf alors et
pour les gens qui ont des vieux
appartements bien sûr
mais brett eelv avec un défaut mais
j'avais la chemise déjà d'un thanou bové
toi et d'annoncés pas ça c'est que
françois bayrou on a les mêmes initiales
parce qu'ils votent baies roses et ça
vous avez déjà un carillon à québec
aussi non
non
non en fait si tu veux me noie metepec
fait quand même ça fait quand
il a appris défini des milliers de pères
damas m c'est parce que ses guérites
sabeg rituel c'est quand même je me sens
gayraud parce que mitterrand lui-même a
dit que ça allait être un future
présentation françois ouimet d'anciens
sont ouverts
moi sinon je change chaque semaine j'ai
dû mater tout ça fait j'ai pas une idée
fixe c'est horrible histoire il ya une
semaine par mois au début j'aimais
beaucoup ségolène royal quand elle
marchait sur l'eau qu'elle était bien en
blanc et touche-à-tout réforme tu vas
lorsqu'on habite oui oui je sais je vole
ça c'est grave ça après j'ai été bon
j'ai eu toute une période d'extrême
gauche bon ça quand même
alors après j'ai déménagé sarkozy comme
tout le monde je fais bo pour une virée
du sarkozysme est gelée vu chez
christine ockrent et j'ai trouvé que
c'était le seul qui connaissait quand
même ces dossiers son boulot qui c'est
un professionnel connaît même pas crédit
sarkozy quand même il dit des trucs qui
sont pragmatiques factuel et bulbes à
tous les héros de la terre oui je sais
qui tu vois elle dit nous et sarkozy ait
dit que je serai présent devant un
public c'était la même dimension que je
peux dire que j'adore la langue
populaire je fais une grande distinction
entre populaire et vulgaire et et pour
moi c'est un homme vulgaire c'est à dire
une bassesse dame qui transpire à
travers son ton et moi je et moi je et
moi je le quitte et une combustion plus
brillants sur les dossiers sur les
réponses systémiques les choses le mur
lui c'est un vendeur devant le les
hommes devant le sénat belge et son père
étaient publicité sur le service public
décédé en publicité cette entreprise
pressé par un salage chef d'entreprise
est il un bon produit s'est lui dit
qu'est ce que tu dis tu es dans ton film
sur sa caisse qui ressort qu'à la fois
que dans la vie c'est quelqu'un de très
sympathique de très drôle de 2 français
connaît l'escroc cette bonne élève de
finir et parallèlement que je pense
qu'ils ne croient pas vraiment à ce
qu'il dit qui est un de problèmes
enfants chirac c'est une enfant de chez
rage mais demain on est face à une
urgence quand même kaki le problème
écologique qui entraîne un problème
économique personne n'en prends
conscience et personne ne vote pour les
gens qui veulent du grand soir qu'il
n'apportera je dis pas n'importe quoi ça
fait quoi tant qu'aucun n'a aucun droit
que j'étudie économique moderne
moi j'ai les points de vie ma vie morin
anémone ce plan je l'avais cours de la
bourse que vous ne comprenez pas c'est
qu'on ne peut pas comprendre l'écologie
sonne l'articulent pas avec l'économie
voilà ce que personne ne comprend c'est
que tout le monde s'imagine que
l'écologie c'est d'une part les petits
oiseaux insectes les candidats et d'un
autre côté mais non c'est pas saison
tournant ce
système totalitaire accra avec ce
système totalitaire
le sailhet ce dîner dans l'échec c'est
la sphère de réfugiés on en parle encore
il va pas mais c'est pour ça qu'on est
les trois plus nul qui sont en tête
c'est parce que personne ne comprend
qu'on ne peut pas séparer l'écologie
d'économie je veux dire anémone c'est
vrai quoi vous en avez tous là parce que
son chien a pissé dans mon couloir tu
avais dit que c'est un pipi de rien du
tout mon bébé
je leur dirai pas plus
si on est sexuellement est libre
et oui encore un peu d'argent tu as
c'est pas dommage si c'est pas dommage
surtout d'avoir toikeuse et ça va
quand même
stéphane seul qu'est ce qui s'passe n'a
connu moi
j'ai connu la vie de couple ouais ça va
j'ai donné à way et je suis très
contente d'être célibataire et qu'elle
paye d'abord vivre dormir seul c'est le
plus grand plaisir du monde
de dormir avec quelqu'un c'est au risque
il à l'iris et s'est réveillée avec
moi j'ai jamais été en jugeant que
j'étais en couple quatre ans avec
michael et que je suis jeune et et -3
j'ai vu d'autres j'ai lu des photos
d'elle zapata qui j'ai lu des polos déjà
d'elisabeth qui dans les sikhs 1 elle
est extrêmement inquiet c'est elsa
pataky on a une grande histoire milliyet
et et avec michaël youn et cailloux ne
sais pas s'il a quitté juliette pour
elsa pataky dans tous les cas mais il a
quitté en tous les cas il va quitter ils
essaient déjà passé à qui est en photo
la presse people cette semaine bon c'est
une signe bombasse un mail arrive à
mettre 12 des gros nichons tu as tu vois
une non mais c'est vrai les magnifiques
mais moi je les ai vus en vrai ça elle
est un défilé avec elle elle est
troublant wifi est la quitter à temps
michaël youn a quitté juliette pour elsa
pataky et elsa pataky y
en roumanie elle a quitté michaël youn
pour adrian brody chihuahua
six mots voir mais qui est un chinois à
l'eau par ah bon bon ballon mais qui
sont ces trois intellectuels tu l'as
déjà entendu en interview rien à redire
non mais attendez
que défend elsa pataky g défense et
mickaël voilà
john paul et tu votes pour kippour move
et au sud
il sera d'abord je te dit pas jamais
pour qui
la mystérieuse ceux ci sont et puis
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je suis super
indécis web mois moi je pense que je
vais dire mais on vote
parce que tu es journaliste interviews
des hommes politiques tous les jours si
tu dis pour qui tu votes c'est la pièce
le regard des téléspectateurs mais il te
dit mais s'il te vois comment
tu vois toi ben je sais pour qui mais je
te le dirais pas pourquoi pourquoi tu
veux rester objectif nos batailles et
journaliste belote sont pas
délaissés
c'est la base du métier de journaliste
karine et ça frédéric pour ça change ça
suffit comme ça à raconter des conneries
frédéric arlat strict les journées sont
une opinion ils doivent la donner
bonsoir josé bové plus apte à vous quand
même sarkozy ce qui compte ce n'est pas
ce qu'on sait c'est que ce qu'on essaye
de nantes c'est très joli c'est à dire
indéniablement mais attention c'est lui
la raison est beau il a absolument
raison il n'est peut-être pas totalement
objectif il le dit lui même je vois
quand je le regarde j'ai l'impression
qu'il est objectif mais lille emerson
totalement tu as envie de penser qu'il
est objective non non je sais
c'est pas parce que je sais que je vais
changer ma façon d'interviewer tel ou
tel candidat excusez moi excusez moi
objection tu prends des spectateurs
foncièrement pour un crétin ça veut dire
qu'il va penser que tu est purement
objectif un mec qui ne sait pas très
bien pour qui il va voter mais les
journalistes marie pezé question peut
être moins ça n'a pas de sens ça n'a
aucun sens si tu es toi ça s'appelle
l'honnêteté cabré objectif
virage peu facho l honnêteté internet et
c'est rien du tout enfin sa vie pour moi
c'est parce que
tu es toi les gens et si ils savent que
tu veux mais ton je sais pas ce que tu
es bon pour apple ils vont dire il dit
ça mais il est pour intel mais c'est pas
grave parce que il fait son compère
l'épandeur les gens répondeur ils savent
très bien à des combattants savent pour
aller plus loin juliette j'ai commis un
bouquin pour aider les indécis à à
choisir tu vois à broadway
on a fait là on a fait la même démarche
avait commis un bouquin s'appelle les
chiffres qui font débat les réponses des
candidats ouais et moi j'ai fait ce
bouquin parce que j'étais totalement
indécis et que je ressentais le besoin
d'accord d'aller plonger dans les
programmateurs d'aller chercher
à l'issue de rédaction de ce livre tu
m'as lançait une conviction du ces pour
qui tu vas voter oui parce que je suis
plonger plonger dans les programmes oui
parce que et ce n'est pas finalement on
parle beaucoup les uns les autres soit
mais parce que moi je suis pas un homme
politique où je suis pas
c'est absolument dégueulasse d'avoir
lourde et duhamel parce que votre bayrou
c'était évident que ce mec il votait pas
ségolène royal je vois ça fait 57 ans
qu'il est là il était clair qu'il
n'était pas là pour défendre nos chevaux
que top que thomas 10 son avis moi je
trouverais ça st parce que c'est
ridicule cette espèce de truc qui fait
que les gens peuvent pas dire fremm pas
d'accord c'est tellement de 3 0 je vais
t'expliquer que contrairement à nous je
ne veux pas tutoyer les politiques en
chine et en
pourtant il y en aurait que je connais
depuis 10 ans ou 15 ans posthume qui
pourraient devenir des copains eh ben je
ne veux pas les tutoyer j'essaie de
garder notre île de plus disent oh
j'essaie de garder une distance d'accord
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille déjà pas
l'air c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
garder parce que j'essaie de garder une
espèce de liberté si je commence à
tutoyer ou si je commence à dire moi je
suis de votre camp ou si je ne suis pas
avec vous moi comme je suis transversale
je vais du front national à l'extrême
gauche et en passant par tour des
intermédiaires comment tu parles au
front national n'en faut dire et je veux
mais ben moi je file j'y vais voir le
pen excuse moi car moi je veux lui
parler
j'y vais alors il lui alors oui c'est
vrai que lui c'est que je suis pas avec
lui ça je lui ai dit il le serait pas
abate ier toile est intervenu à la porte
quand c'est terminé c'est terminé
faut dire car la raison tu dis je ne dis
pas pour qui je vote c'est une position
mais nous mais je me bats pour ne pas te
dire que tu dis pour marcher sur 10 et
j'ai la manifester contre le pen
c'était bien c'était la limite peut-être
que je suis sorti de mon rôle et
j'espère ne pas ressortir de mon rôle
qu'est ce qu'ils disent dans le poitou
sur ségo alors ceux qui l'ont fréquenté
ouais
10 et décrivent un monstre et moi j'ai
croisés dans le train et c'est vrai que
cette femme qui est tellement vais pas
qu'il y ait des gens car mentalement
tout ça tue la croix puisque je faisais
la queue derrière elle tue c'est au bar
le tgv écoute elle a un regard mais de
fée carabosse non c'est ce que tu dis là
pour un homme c'est un truc qu'on
n'entend l'ump tous les deux jours ça de
quoi leur discours c'est à dire ceux qui
connaissent nicolas sarkozy ils l'aiment
ceux qui connaissent ségolène royal il
quand je l'attends bon parce que son
discours si tu veux fait que de toute
façon comme moi c'est tout sauf sarkozy
je mettrai pourrait le traditions
d'apporter tout sauf sarkozy sio
deuxième toyas le ppj tu veux te ra
sarkozy non je ne les rendra le pen le
pen
baptisé le monde pourquoi vous
souhaitiez josé bové
la logique
c'est quand même lui ni même pas
d'extrême droite c'est l'absolue
milliardaire grotesque compo de la pop
qui font semblant de 6,23 voilà
ou moins dangereux de sarkozy a vu dans
mesrine appel à pareil derrière et vous
voilà vous êtes tous pris de folie des
folies c'est toi qui abrite folie
annonce à sa tante regard de cette croix
regarde ces trois là prononce aussi
pour votre premier tour et après on
dépouille ont fait 2e tour
[Musique]
oh
à ma chance jacquot non mais je veux que
ça soit fait du placement du conseil
constitutionnel je suis je suis jean
louis debré je veux dire à voter alors à
voter
[Musique]
diallo reçoit abdellah taïa wii ou
quatrième merci
jeu thomas hugues qui vous plaît donnez
je pense qu'il va voter laurence ferrari
voilà ma change mais c'est même pas
aller à lens merci
bourguignon s'il vous plaît
22h50 au jeu que je pense que c'est cher
et que tu m'amènes un troisième il est
très mignon effet amiens
désolé désolé
[Musique]
pour
dauber roue de l'es2 sarko à ségolène un
mauvais 1 voix n'est et deux blancs ça
fait quoi comme deuxième tour la
deuxième tous ses bureaux au
2ème tour maintenant que je veux tu en
voilà
on aime s'y met maintenant pour alors
que pour elle au second allons-y
non il est honnête et rouge
attention chjama chou blanc avec bing
non pas que la
d2 sarkozy nicolas a mis d'accord
parmi nous qui revit nous est saine il
ya eu deux roues non sans causer
douzaine de sa demeure de
0,2 par tous deux parties mais où trois
vallées aux trois lions mais au coeur à
ça bascule
[Musique]
ce jeune homme ce jeu est un remarquable
écrivain marocain qui écrit en français
de 30 ans que j'ai rencontré en faisant
une émission de télé mise de radio avec
lui vers et je cherchais quelqu'un avec
qui rédiger
un livre de photographies sur le maroc
fort je lui ai demandé tout à trac le
maroc histoire du budget nous sommes en
studio merveilleusement bien et il est
absolument délicieux il n'est pas ville
fred et karim nous avons une relation
parfaitement platonique sinon vraiment
très bien très bien sûr je confirme
frédéric c'est quoi ces images qui
datent donc des protectorats y qui est
qui dormaient dans les archives du quai
d'orsay a nantes il en bas l'ancien
ambassadeur de france au maroc a passé
cette commande à frédéric qui est la
gentillesse de penser à moi et donc on a
fait un choix ensemble et on a passé
pratiquement tout l'été dernier à la
faire le film est
intitulé de
marquise la mamounia
a2a buman au maire furieux de voir que
les français d'aujourd'hui qui montrent
leur maison au maroc à tire larigot sans
aucune gêne somptueuse dans les années
30 salle des aînés oui et donc il y en a
pas beaucoup
m
non
bientôt oui c'est ma théorie et marie
jeanne
oui au quatrième
[Musique]
le
guaino bonsoir
tout commence ici le tapis alors tapis
c'est en définitive pour rien c'est pas
bien à les aider mais quand tu fais là
quand tu fais l'amour tu fume pas de
pétard thomas par exemple banon
j'avais terry contrebas de la patinoire
bonjour
[Musique]
les tickets
je te
si je ne me trompe
pas
le monde
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
est
m
bon et c'est sûr
modou lô
il est où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ans
oui elle peut
m
au
bout
et
vous
oui
m
[Applaudissements]
et corrections de ne rien rater de la
latitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu